bien nos quedamos en el problema número
7 problema número 7 y vamos a resolverlo
dice ahmed tiene contenedores de dos
distintos tamaños igual me da mucho
gusto que ahora estén intentando poner
nombres étnicos como amer en los
problemas del s
me siento más identificado pero bueno lo
hicimos el problema ahmed tiene
contenedores de dos distintos tamaños la
capacidad total de 16 contenedores del
mismo tamaño es de x litros ok a ver
veamos vamos con calma tenemos dos
contenedores de distintos tamaños así
que voy a ponerle aquí el contenedor 1
este tiene un cierto tamaño y por acá
tengo otros contenedores y los voy a
llamar contenedores 2 de otro tamaño
distinto y dice la capacidad total de 16
contenedores del mismo tamaño es de x
litros así que imagínate que agarramos
de estos vamos a agarrar 16 entonces 16
contenedores de la capacidad número 1 es
igual a x litros
ok esto por una parte después nos dice y
la capacidad total de 8 contenedores del
otro tamaño es decir de ese 2
otro tamaño recuerda que solamente
tenemos dos tamaños entonces van a ser
los contenedores número 2 2
también es de equis litros la capacidad
total de ocho contenedores ocho veces
los contenedores número dos es de x
litros también x litros y lo que me
preguntan es
ah por cierto me dicen que x es mayor o
igual que 0 pero bueno eso también lo
podemos deducir porque no podemos tener
litros negativos ok en términos de x
cuál es la capacidad en litros del
contenedor con mayor capacidad en
términos de x en términos de x de x cuál
es la capacidad en litros del contenedor
con mayor capacidad o que hay perfecto
tenemos dos contenedores y lo que
necesitamos saber es cuál de ellos tiene
mayor capacidad y bueno vamos a leerlo
con calma dice 16 contenedores
del tipo 1 del tipo 1 es igual a x
litros y por otra parte ocho
contenedores del tipo 2 es igual a x
litros por lo tanto aquí ya podemos ver
que son mucho más grandes los
contenedores tipo 2 los contenedores
tipo 2 son mucho más grandes que los
contenedores tipo 1 porque con 8 de
éstos se forman lo mismo que lo que
formamos con 16 de los contenedores tipo
y es más de aquí podremos despejar de
ambas ecuaciones y aquí al contenedor 1
el contenedor 1 es lo mismo que x litros
litros entre 16 y el contenedor 2 de
esta ecuación me va a quedar x litros
entre 8 y si te das cuenta si tenemos
algo y lo dividimos en 16 partes esto es
mucho más pequeño que tomarnos algo y
dividirlo entre 8 partes por lo tanto la
respuesta es justo esta que el
contenedor de 2 visto en x litros es lo
mismo que x litros entre 8 el contenedor
2 es x litros entre 8 y por cierto es la
respuesta número de elipsis un número de
muy bien un problema número 7
y bueno lo importante es que debes de
leer estos problemas con mucho cuidado
así que vamos al problema número 8
8 y 16 en el rectángulo a veces y bueno
es que yo sigo emocionado por el nombre
de ahmed porque es un nombre muy
parecido al mío tal vez próximamente
pongan mi nombre en uno de estos
problemas y yo me sentiré profundamente
motivado y muy agradecido mi verdadero
nombre es salman y aunque todos me dicen
sal que por cierto es una abreviación de
mi nombre y no porque no me siento
orgulloso de mi nombre
más bien me dicen sal porque así me
llama mi mamá de hecho mi nombre
completo es salman khan y yo me siento
bastante orgulloso de mi nombre y este
es justo el nombre de un actor indio que
seguramente tiene más seguidores que yo
con mis vídeos de khan academy pero
bueno así es la vida
vamos a dibujar
en el rectángulo pero para esto creo que
es todo un plano cartesiano ok vamos a
dibujar el plano cartesiano me gusta
este color color de plano que sean o
algo así
khan academy
algo así ok y me dicen que este es el
eje de las equis que este es el eje de
las 10 y me dicen que tengo un
rectángulo abc de el cual no tiene
ningún lado paralelo al eje x por lo
tanto no es un rectángulo de este estilo
porque tendremos un lado paralelo al eje
x debe de ser un rectángulo más o menos
así imagínatelo así así así o algo así
tengo un rectángulo parecido a éste no
sé bien pero es un rectángulo parecido a
este y tengo aquí un ángulo de 90 grados
aquí otros 90 grados otros 90 grados y
otro de 90 grados ok lo que quiero que
te des cuenta es que como es un
rectángulo entonces podemos construir
algunas cosas esta recta es paralela a
esta recta porque es un rectángulo y
esta recta es paralela a esta recta ok
ahora qué es lo que nos preguntan
precisamente lo que nos preguntan es
cuánto vale el producto o la
multiplicación de las pendientes de las
cuatro rectas que forman a este
rectángulo ok pendientes pendientes
vamos a utilizar este color bien si esta
recta esta recta de aquí tiene una
pendiente llamada m entonces esta recta
de aquí podemos concluir que también
tiene una pendiente llamada m y cómo
podemos saber eso bueno porque son dos
rectas paralelas y recuerda que si
tenemos dos rectas paralelas tienen la
misma pendiente de hecho esa es una
forma de ver a dos rectas paralelas si
tenemos dos rectas con la misma
pendiente son paralelas eso es
importantísimo y no sólo eso aquí se
forma un ángulo de 90 grados es decir
que estas dos rectas son perpendiculares
y cuando tenemos rectas perpendiculares
se cumplía algo con las pendientes la
pendiente de la otra recta era el
inverso multiplicativo negativo de la
otra es decir que este va a ser menos
uno entre
el inverso multiplicativo 1 / m es el
inverso multiplicativo de m pero
negativo y esto se da porque tenemos
rectas perpendiculares perpendiculares
aquí también y de igual manera para acá
como estas dos rectas son paralelas
deben de tener la misma pendiente o
dicho de otra manera
con estas dos rectas son perpendiculares
entonces la pendiente de esta es el
inverso multiplicativo negativo de la
otra ok y ya con eso podemos sacar el
producto de todas ellas pues vamos a ver
m lo voy a multiplicar por menos 1 entre
m ya esto lo voy a multiplicar por m y
esto lo voy a multiplicar por menos 1
entre m y cuánto va a ser esto
bueno pues date cuenta que estas dos
estas dos como son perpendiculares o si
lo quieres ver de otra manera el
producto de estas dos siempre va a ser
menos 1 y tiene toda la lógica del mundo
más x menos es menos m por sumersión
multiplicativo pues eso
y estas dos estados
tenemos la suerte de que son
perpendiculares o podemos multiplicar
las directos es lo mismo que menos uno
realmente lo que estamos haciendo es
multiplicando menos uno por menos uno lo
cual por cierto es 1
1 y es el insisto de el inciso de que es
un bueno ok problema número 8 borremos
la pantalla problema número 9 dice en
una hora de programación televisiva
normal en una hora se incluyen 20
minutos de comerciales ok entonces en
una hora de televisión desde la división
20 minutos son de comerciales 20 minutos
son comerciales comerciales mientras que
nosotros
supongo que son 40 minutos 40 minutos
son no comerciales comerciales ok me
dicen que fracción de la hora televisiva
no son comerciales es decir que ver qué
fracción no son comerciales es decir
esos 40 minutos qué fracción representan
de una hora pero bueno esto es visto
como una fracción sería tomar unos 40
entre una hora pero una hora son 60
minutos para que tengamos todo en la
misma unidad y aquí este terrorista se
reservan y me queda 4 sobre 6 lo cual
son dos tercios entonces la respuesta de
este problema número nueve son dos
tercios y estamos bien
problema número 10 dice si el producto
de 0.3 con un cierto número es igual a 1
de qué número hablamos el producto de
0.3 con un cierto número a digamos x
esto va a ser igual a 1 de que el número
hablamos pues bueno podemos despejar de
aquí a x x es igual a 1 entre 0.3 y
cuantos esto tanto lo podríamos calcular
haciendo la decisión pero qué te parece
si recorremos el punto a una vez y para
recorrer el punto una vez pues voy a
multiplicar arriba por 10 y abajo por 10
y esto me va a quedar 10 entre 3 que por
cierto es lo mismo que tres enteros un
tercio visto como un número mixto y ya
está a 10 sobre t es aquí está aquí está
en las respuestas perfecto problema
número 10 también estuvo bastante fácil
problema número
11 número 11 dice lo siguiente para
todos estos problemas me encantan en los
problemas en los que definimos funciones
para todos los enteros positivos x de
zeta definimos
y aquí tengo un triángulo aquí tengo un
triángulo y me dice x y z esto es
exactamente lo mismo como x al menos se
está elevado también a la y ok lo que me
preguntan es cuánto vale
10 triángulo cuidado con este triángulo
10 35 pues bueno utilizando la
definición de esta función esto es lo
mismo que 10 elevado al cubo menos 5
elevado al cubo en este caso x vale 10
llévale 37 vale 5 y cuántos esto esto es
lo mismo que 10 y le ponemos tres ceros
entonces nos va a quedar mil mil menos
cinco al cubo 5 por 5 225 por 5 es 125
125 ok y esto es lo mismo que 1000 menos
100 es 900 900 menos 25 es 875 y ya está
10 35 entre milito a utilizando las
definiciones 875 bien problemas número
11 problema número 12 tiene una figura
como la siguiente vamos a hacerlo
problema número 12
tenemos 1
rectángulo por aquí y tenemos por aquí
por aquí tenemos una línea parecida a
ésta y nos dicen que este es el ver tan
gul o p
q
r s t
ok y me dicen p
es igual a 5 p es igual a 5 perfecto y
después me dicen que p q s t es un
rectángulo mientras que rus7 es un
cuadrado es un cuadrado este de aquí es
un cuadrado y no sólo eso me dicen que
usted es un entero positivo y bueno es
positivo y eso tiene toda la lógica del
mundo porque no puede ser negativo
porque no tenemos longitudes negativas
pero lo importante es que me dice que es
un entero entonces este lado es un
entero
ok me dicen si el área de pq st ok vamos
a ponerlo el área de pq de pq st
es decir de todo este rectángulo es a
más grande que 10 y menor que 30 ok
vamos a ponerlo así el área es menor que
30 unidades pero es más grande que 10
unidades
me dicen cuál es un posible valor de
utep cuál es un posible valor de esto
que tengo aquí y es más para no
complicarnos la vida voy a decir que
esto esto es igual a equis y si esto es
igual a equis esto también se cuela x
esto también es igual a equis y esto
también porque estamos hablando de un
cuadrado ok
como saco el área de un rectángulo bueno
pues el área de organizamos la base es
la base pero la base es a 5
+ x 5 x ok estoy sacando el área el área
de p
st efe
de p esp en el área de este rectángulo
aquí es igual a la base que multiplica a
la altura pero la altura de este
rectángulo vale x porque este es un
cuadrado este lado mide lo mismo que
este lado y por lo tanto la altura vale
x o dicho otra manera o no espera de
hecho déjame utilizar los mismos colores
ok o dicho de otra manera esto es lo
mismo que x cuadrado más 5 x x cuadrada
más 5 x y recuerda que esta área justo
esto de aquí tiene que ser más grande
que 10 y menor que 30 y lo que me
preguntan es cuál es un posible valor de
utem puedes un posible valor de x
entonces qué te parece si variamos a x
sabiendo que es un entero positivo
imagínate que x valga 1 si x vale 1
cuánto vale el área el área valdría 15
serían 6 unidades 6 unidades 16 es un
número que no está entre 10 y 30 por lo
tanto uno no funciona qué pasa si x vale
2 me quedaría 4 4 10 lo cual es 14 el
área sería 14 y qué creés esto si me
funciona ya encuentre un valor posible
para usted cuando usted x vale 2 el área
que vale 14 está entre 10 y 30 y se
cumplen todas las hipótesis de este
problema así que el problema número 12
ya está resuelto